acteurs économiques partenaires privés
sportif dans cette salle pour parler du
38e tour cycliste international de
martinique
les festivités démarrent le 6 juillet
prochain pour s'achever le 14 premières
étapes 1 fort-de-france fort-de-france
138 km et cette année les communes du
quart des fonds sein de nier
saint-esprit sont des villes étapes
petit changement sur sept maris cette
marine ne feront plus l'arrivée alors
déçu farinas hiver entraînant vu qu'ils
aillent là même de travaux cette malle
bodmer on est une nouveauté qui est le
nom d'arriver au camp berre et puis
l'après-midi en contre la montre
ça fait très longtemps qu'on a pas vu ça
en martinique en contre la montre
pendant le tour de martinique qui est
plus ou moins contre la monte en
montagne
le spectacle sera beau et c'est déjà là
déjà là le dimanche 7
dans l'après midi nous aurons
un petit un peu petite idée du vainqueur
du tour cycle de vente unique des
invités la guadeloupe et la guyane comme
d'habitude mais aussi les états unis les
seychelles la grande bretagne la france
il va falloir se battre pour décrocher
un maillot ya un excellent cyclisme
niveau de ces crises en martinique donc
tout le monde veut venir chez nous mais
sur cette certaines conditions je répète
que mon objectif c'est de développer le
cyclisme martiniquais un public
important est attendu dans quelques
jours sur nos hôtes et juste après cette
édition le président du comité régional
l'a annoncé
les assises du tour cycliste de
martinique